[Music]
all right well i'll tell you what i can
do for you some new transient removals
how's that for everybody we've come with
that
speaking of penis
no
security is that you is that your sister
alright he said no
it's not your sister the the no is
universal
all questions
it's an always accomplishing now
i was gonna say what do you think about
[ __ ]
yeah got him
security open up please
open up kill ready
charity
security open up please
can you imagine opening your door and
seeing teddy long and a [ __ ] police
ride
security any challenge i'm here to
inform you that you're in a quick
match
oh how's the attack team play i was
gonna do undertaker you're going an
attack team player versus undertaker and
kane
there you go boom now you got both
there you go
hello miss open up please
no i don't open up to black people
security
open the door i'm not going to talk to
you through the door miss just open up
and i'll tell you what's what
what if she's naked
okay all right give me one second all
right all right
so my guess it sounds asian
yeah um sex trafficked
i want to say
weird old weird kind of middle age to
old lady
and uh they're getting complaints
because she's just deep frying stuff
this is schrodinger this is
schrodinger's transient we don't know
what we're getting behind the store
we have no idea schrodinger's bum yeah
bum exactly we have no idea what's
behind this door and i'll be honest with
you i for one am loving the suspense
um what do you think she's doing drugs
um
opioids
and
she's laying sideways just smoking from
a long opium pipe like old school
you [ __ ] people
uh
they only do that below ground
or or or or if like if like a british
detective is looking for jack the ripper
they'll go into like an opium then
a [ __ ] from hell reference oh what do
you drop okay yeah i was gonna say would
you drop
probably
open the door please i just dropped this
all right open the door please is that a
from here just take a second yeah just
open the door and i'll tell you where
that goes wow you got it
remember that movie
that dude i read the comic book first
oh that's right good point yeah i don't
know it's like i was just saying like i
read the comic book first and then like
years later i was like oh they made it
into a movie
okay good what is what does he think
right does she think that if she takes
long he's just going to give up
okay
wow i love this guy this guy is not
stopping the knock
ma'am i have a card to the door i'm just
gonna open it in a second
knock knock knocking on hobos doors
so what will win this guy's persistence
or
the
the asian woman's patience
security guy's gonna win we've seen his
setup we've seen his whole
the guy does not it's not like losing
sir stop knocking i'm trying to slice a
bean what if the next thing he does is
just start shooting through the door
i mean he's armed to the teeth
get him at the door get him out the
window right god that's so annoying
if i was another if i was another guest
at this 5 star motel 8 i'd be pretty
pissed
go ahead yeah if i was in 133 i'd be
angry
i'm trying to sleep
well she can call the police
all she has to do is open the door and i
for me to tell her what i need to tell
her and i'll be on my way but she
doesn't want to cooperate
got a noise complaint coming from this
room
oh wait
oh was it a guy banging on the [ __ ]
door
by the way
a noise complaint there's nothing she
could have been doing that's more
annoying than this guy knocking right
yeah
to be fair though actually you could
hear her screaming at the top of this
video
right frozen like you heard it right yes
that's why frozen immediately was like
no it's not me because you could
immediately hear like
i got like
[ __ ]
yeah i'm to keep knocking until she
answers
open the door man what you want
me to answer you what you want
um just open the door for a brief okay
hold on
hear me out here if this is about a
noise complaint she could clearly hear
him right
why don't you just say it through a
closed door ma'am you need to keep the
voice down we're getting noise
complaints
because you guys we forg you're
forgetting remember this guy is a
aggressor this guy is uh arrogant piece
of [ __ ]
he's so aggressive
top top comment made more noise uh we'll
call the police wait so long
ma'am just open the door just even even
crack it and i'll be on my way
i'm just crap
talking too loud
there she is oh
yeah i had the fast forward to see if he
actually did it
you said one second
okay ma'am sorry to bother you getting
noise
complaint oh my god
look at the finger look at the pointing
finger wait hear me out if if she called
the front desk
the front desk could have told her over
the phone we're getting a noise
complaint
this guy is annoying i mean i'll never
stop playing his videos because he has
good interactions but he's he's the
problem like 50 of the time right
50 of the time
and even when he isn't the problem he's
like no better he's still power trips
and [ __ ] so he just makes it more
entertaining like no it always escalates
with this guy and it's [ __ ] great
he talks to everyone like they're a
child yeah he's aggressive okay just
keep it down
okay i also saw what he looked like
but you know why he does this
because because he needs content for his
youtube channel see that's the other
problem with this is like this guy
this what do you want you know maybe she
was being loud i'm not trust me she was
probably being loud and annoying
probably on a phone with a boyfriend or
some [ __ ] right
um
but
again
if you've ever been to a hotel you've
been in a situation where you've heard
the room neck door screaming or loud or
whatever having a party that happens
right
but what he did was so much worse
you know instead of just like hey keep
it even through the door keep it down he
did this to make sure that he knew that
he was this guy really is kind of a
piece of [ __ ] right now if i have to
come back
for another have you remember okay
please
all right
we understand each other all right thank
you very much she's got crabs
by the way
i thought she was a junkie but either
way
why did he upload this
it was a slow week that week
big
what you want ma'am
keep it down
have a nice day why
but
uh but why
but why
are there any videos a company like
after this or before this
no
that it was a slow week for him what was
that
he needed something to upload
here we go homeless guy
wait is he homeless
or is he a drug dealer
i'm sorry i knew i said you can't be on
the property unless you have a room
oh look at that hair oh
what's a hat that head it's a hat that's
a hat what
oh it is jesus
i christ he had weird hair
yeah his hair was shaped like a hat
well remember we had that last guy where
it was literally just the back of a
mullet
i remember this spot this is where he
yeah oh i know this i could i could draw
this place by memory
was that it
not seriously was that here right
security
hold on
hello
all right um
there's not supposed to be anyone in
this room
uh oh somebody snuck into a room
excuse me
there's nothing uh this room is we're
just still to anyone you're not supposed
to be in here you got to leave
okay
right okay now please
wait so this guy
just walked into a room say yes took his
shoes off
and and later not laid on a bed
what shouldn't these doors automatically
lock or something
to get in right
he was sleepy
she was sleepy
i saw sleepy
i [ __ ] holmes i was having the best
dream about like titties and [ __ ]
you think he's on drugs
but buddy has like waking apnea because
of all the [ __ ] he has on him
so much [ __ ] [ __ ] on me
this is like when a kid doesn't want to
leave so you see the parents like
telling him to leave and they're putting
the shoes on like super slow on purpose
gonna eat your pop-tart before we leave
hurry up and put your shoes on
right jj god
he has his bike in there
wait what look look at that
i'm still wondering how he got in there
door might have been left open a little
bit
what is he doing
that's a bit of patience right now man
i'd have been in that door get the [ __ ]
out of here dude
no no no no no no no no remember
something we know something about
security guys something that we've
learned
security guy only gets uppity and rough
and in people's faces [ __ ] like that
when it's a woman or like a weak person
whenever it's someone that could be
potentially dangerous
he's giving this guy more time in a room
that he didn't pay for
to put on his shoes comb his hair take a
piss take a [ __ ] brush teeth then he did
the lady for after he kept knocking
because she was too loud a woman who did
pay for a room
because he knows one is threatening and
one is just a little asian lady
like the guy the guy earlier in this
video when he was on the stairs yeah
he just completely forgot about him
and just moved on
with this kind of hotels everyone's
andre yeah yeah any motel later motel 6
or any motel in general is usually
people that are on drugs
drugs or prostitutes if the word motel
is in there you you probably want to
avoid that
you know you gotta take your back
[Music]
wow it's not even like
that these home it's not even that
homeless people
are annoying it's that
the new home new homeless not old
homeless new homeless as we've seen as
all the people that we've covered
new homeless are so entitled have you
noticed how entitled new homeless are
yeah
like it used to be we didn't have that
bike yesterday he stole that so i mean
obviously he forgot he owned it yeah i
know i know but it's like yeah man you
know i'm gonna take as long as i want
though even though it's like
this this that guy took that long
because he was taking a leak he is
giving this guy so much more leeway than
an asian girl who was too loud it's so
funny to see what a [ __ ] this guy
actually is
right
no you gotta take your bike
[Music]
if i'm this guy i'm going in there
grabbing the bike and throwing it on the
floor yeah
do your [ __ ] dude
wait he has a car
most new homeless have cars wait hold on
though is this the guy with the bike
yeah same guy
huh
sleep in your car
hey i'm almost out of here like couple
20 minutes
i wait for the people right there i give
50 bucks for them they say he's wrong
i'm going to wait here for speaking
english i'm going to wait here for 10
minutes
because i'm waiting for these people
over there and i'll give you 50 bucks
for the room a drug dealer
bucks for the room right
i'm gonna wait like 30 minutes and keep
coming i'm asking for my money all right
no i leave okay this is my car are you
going to sit in your car yeah 30 minutes
30 minutes uh that's fine that's fine
wait a second why is he giving this guy
more leeway than anybody i've ever seen
him we've covered a lot of this dude
right yep yeah it seems like he wouldn't
let anybody else just sit in their car
right like he's the other people for
just being one foot on the mcdonald's
property one foot on the motel property
he probably knows what he is and is like
probably shouldn't mexican
well i mean he's if he's waiting 30
minutes for someone's money
yeah yeah yeah either he's pimping a
[ __ ] out or
i don't think it's a pimp thing i think
it's a drug thing
this guy doesn't give me pimp vibes i'm
telling me he's gonna keep coming a
little
okay all right i leave both that's fine
thank you
thank you
i bet you he mumbles and talks [ __ ] when
the guy's not hearing to around watch
watch [ __ ] know this guy [ __ ]
watch
hold on
wait a minute
oh he doesn't have the mask this time
he looks like such a [ __ ] [ __ ] all
the time dude he looks like that urban
defense [ __ ] exactly what he looks
like that detroit urban defense guy
tactical urban tactical urban
yep it's a disgusting motel bathtub just
like you expected
this is what you protect you [ __ ]
loser i know exactly this is your life
i'm a castle one of the bulbs is out
oh don't show the bed i don't want to
see the bed thank you
he's doing a lot of what i like to call
rasa frassa
and
rashford
when you're mad but you don't want to be
loud but you're also just [ __ ]
preaching
that home alone joe pesci swearing
frost that's what he's doing yes
somebody's calling him tacticool
nice
the guy was laying in the bed i don't
know what are you doing
lying in my bed at a motel a
this black guy keeps bothering me he's
saying i'm too loud [ __ ] my dominican
girlfriend he's an idiot he should go
back to africa
have we found his new channel yet i
don't need to find his new channel i'm
friends with him on facebook i know
where he is at all times
he's ocd he has to do it exactly five
times
now he turns around and does it again
because of his ocd he stops right here
turns around and does it again
i was gonna say he turns around a split
second later and the mexican guy's back
on the bed with his shoes up and no and
and his family and you here
and there's like there's
there's an entire pig cooking in the
bathtub
no
well what's going on here
uh oh
that's not supposed to be anyone in
their room man that's not supposed to be
anyone in this room no no
i already chased someone out here
earlier there's a guy that needed the
drugs wait wait why is the door open
again what's happening that's was i
right
see i'm you were joking but no that's
what just happened
what
there's not supposed to be anyone in
their room man
that's not supposed to be anyone in this
room no no
i already chased someone out here
earlier
yeah no earlier tonight there's not
supposed to no not supposed to be anyone
in here this room is not registered no
one's supposed to be in this room
no no no no no i'm sorry you know better
you should know better than that i think
one of the housekeepers has the key and
he just keeps giving it back one of the
housekeepers is using it as a [ __ ] shack
i'm sorry that wouldn't that would mean
that a housekeep one of those
housekeepers would have to be mexican
and i've never seen one of those
true
a mexican housekeeper
i mean next thing you're gonna tell me
you've seen an african guy that doesn't
have yellow in his eyes
seriously it's like you'll never see one
front desk i'm gonna have to get
a lot bigger gun
i got card lockout key for uh 176 i just
ran someone else out of here
just a couple of minutes ago
who is this
all you hear is
steve we keep telling you you don't work
here
you haven't worked here in a year please
leave
plea you're the one that needs to be
removed
what do you think was going on in that
room now it's really feeling like drug
deal right
drug dealer i'm saying pam i got my
money on pimp though
because we're talking about mexicans and
investors
oh yeah mexicans don't sell drugs oh
jj froze uh oh j i'm frozen
you're not you're no i mean you're
frozen but jj froze
oh no it's that hillbilly internet
uh oh boy it's that hillbilly the weed
was too strong yeah
jesus christ what happened that was
weird no it was super weird your
internet just kind of [ __ ] just went
like you you were in the middle of it
you were in the middle of explaining to
us why you thought it was a pimp
because you said the last thing i heard
was because mexicans because mexicans
love to pay for sex yeah but mexicans
also love to sell fentanyl see that's
the other
that's why i'm stuck on the drug dealer
side
yeah
i mean look i i hear what you're saying
how about this this is this mean in the
middle
it's probably been both at some point
this guy probably sells fentanyl and is
a pimp yeah i think hour one was when he
left the housekeeper in there to get her
to work
hour two is after the sex you sell them
fentanyl
i mean it's actually brilliant if you
think about it
please meet me in my office wait that's
just a motel late don't worry the door's
open
[Laughter]
great now i'm starting to wonder if i
hit my uh upload limit you know they're
starting to throttle me
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait wait
i've heard some internet companies do
that yours does that yeah like when you
use up enough of it they just say look
no more for the month and then you have
to wait till the end of the month until
you get your full speed back yeah but
it's in your contract if you read it but
who's your internet provider
uh comcast
it's not in mine i have i mean i i have
a frontier and i don't which used to be
for fire i'm i'm just you know i'm being
a dick
but now but not but now i'm wondering if
like bright well it's called spectrum
now i'm wondering
i i'm what it is it's really called
spectrum now yeah i'm one right now all
right i got 391 down and uh what's that
22 up so it's you know
i think my internet just had a fart you
know that happens when you pay the bill
and you don't go over your usage limit
but when you go over that usage limit
you know let's see
24 hours a day
if you go over that limit
near the end of the month you're gonna
have to get throttled yeah but my point
is is like i
i mean
i use a lot of data because of the show
but look also i'm gonna i'm gonna guess
because i don't pay for the lowest tier
okay right i'm a fancy guy i like a lot
of internet so what are you mid-tier you
meant here yeah i'm mid-tier i'm not
full-tier yeah you're probably full-tier
right i got right now i just did a
download i got uh one gigabyte down and
800 up
yeah so you pay for the good [ __ ]
and uh
you know
and then when you call get something
fixed they come over and fix it you know
yeah but what's funny is like what you
told me about them throttling you i've
heard of that but
with phone companies like i've heard of
like you know phone companies when they
tell you you have unlimited data but in
reality you have unlimited 10 gigabytes
of data and after that you have data but
it'll be down to like 3g like yeah well
that's what happens in the lower poverty
once they actually get over top of
people
so you we're we're in the uh refined
uh upper middle class i would say
right right
whereas if someone was on the poverty
level paying just the bare minimum uh
they would actually have to enact
the [ __ ] inside of all the texts
that we didn't read because we were like
[ __ ] right yeah [ __ ] it i don't care i'm
paying for this i just want internet
yeah yeah shut the [ __ ] up
and you know i'm just saying
does that happen down there it happens
up here
yeah it's in my comcast contract if i
don't i mean maybe i i don't know you
might be right i i've never experienced
it so i don't know
i haven't either because i just paid
money yeah
come on let's go
let's go move it along wait is this i
think we've seen this one right this is
the towel yeah this is that chick
or is she back no hold on let me look
because i think i think no no no no no
because they were over next to the
dumpster that's the same one
yeah they think that he probably has
multiple interactions with yeah because
he that's one that he knows
i've just been i'm playing some of these
because i i've missed quite a few like
i'm behind on
on this guy you know hold on can you go
back to the just can you quickly just go
back to the beginning of this uh pause
it um can you play the baby elephant
walk
i'm sorry this guy is such a bumbling
[ __ ] i can't
do
and it's not because he's fat he's not
fat it's because he has so much super
encumbered exactly
oh he's in a fat roll he's like a skyrim
carrot he's like when you pick he's like
when you first start playing uh skyrim
and all you do is pick up cabbage
[Music]
all right you have a room here
[Music]
no i'm asking you which wrong
i'm not going to tell you what's going
on so you can harass me brother
no i'm not harassing you i'm just asking
them
i want to tell you what
i want you to wrap my room
harassing
look at him look at him look at me
tweaking he's tweaking right
yeah
oh
i think he smells blood in the water
[Music]
how is he gonna ignore
[Music]
nope
[Music]
[Music]
i can't do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
royce he goes in he goes into the
he goes into like the office and it just
goes it just goes
[Music]
[Laughter]
then he opens the door and walks out and
then you hear
[Music]
i don't normally clip these but i'm
gonna have to taper clip this
specifically just so i can send him this
clip
and make him so mad that nobody takes
him seriously
and not telling me
what room he's in i'm just trying to
find out whether he belongs here or not
why is he so scared of this guy because
he's not a little asian lady
bro
cracker tweet bro um he's on the uh he's
near the um gas station next to the um
fun office
it's like royce it's like banjo-kazooie
like he dives into water
there's like different versions of the
songs
correct
all right thank you
[Music]
i guarantee you that this cop hates the
security guard
i guarantee you that this cop
[ __ ] cannot stand him
if he had a room here refuse to give me
an answer
so like what do you want me to do about
it
i don't know she was no better than me
officer fade over here
nothing wrong with it
all right
[Music]
you're not supposed to stand outside
no that's not what you said you said you
had a room there
that's not what you said you said you
had a room there
oh
is that another cop hold up yeah it
looks like it
what happened tough guys
uh
yeah
yeah i just need to know for sure
whether he had a roomy or not because
yeah and that's that's something
i know it's your job to figure out who's
staying here who's not and [ __ ] like
that but if they don't want to disclose
it to you technically i don't think they
[ __ ] have to
[Laughter]
it's what we call getting put in your
place oh that's called failing the
police entrance exam and becoming a
security guard and then a real cops
telling you that you [ __ ] suck yeah i
don't realize that
toasty's already getting you know antsy
yeah
what's he gonna do shave her head again
like i said you know he was suspicious
looking in the car yeah i'm just saying
she's [ __ ] i don't i don't i don't i
don't care what jada puerto rican smith
says stuff like
that don't make it for her as long as i
know that he doesn't it's fine we're
long here that's cool puerto rican
powder
that's all to recast it's a to latinx
woman in the recasting of the movie
powder
in her mind she thinks she's stone cold
puerto rican